coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 31 so did
you see this new Google video floating
around Project Glass in which all the
information that you can access on your
smartphone is put into these very sleek
glasses and made a part of your regular
vision that surprised me that Google put
this ad out because it must mean they
think that there are more people who
would see this and say wow that's
amazing I want that than those who would
almost reflexively be terrified by it
the video was shot in first-person so as
to put the viewer in the experience and
I wonder if I was the only one who felt
a palpable sense of intrusion when the
first icons launched into vision the
whole ad functions is a sort of metaphor
for social media something that is
wedging its way into our lives in the
culture so successfully that we can't
help but to participate in it with
everyone else this is the effect of all
new technologies they create needs that
you did not have before needs which you
can abstain from satisfying or even
recognizing but only until they apply to
that critical mass of people at that
point not to use the technology actually
puts you at a disadvantage in
communication people begin to get angry
with you right and you're all but forced
to conform think of cellphones you can
choose not to have one but are you
willing to suffer the frustration and
displeasure of all those who feel
entitled to get in touch with you at any
time you can cling to your principles
but what happens when those principles
come into tension with relationships
you're not willing to compromise you may
say you don't want to be friends with
anyone who doesn't respect your choice
not to be plugged in that might work
today with Facebook and Twitter but not
really anymore with cell phones right
what job today doesn't require you to
have a cell phone
have a smartphone it's in this way that
technology's wedge themselves into the
culture over time individually you may
disagree with the technology but you
like everyone else has a stake in
culture so as far as the culture accepts
Facebook Twitter cell phone smart phones
etc you'll have to compromise your
values to the extent that you want to
participate
we're all pulled along by the wave of
culture
maybe tomorrow you decide that you'll
never watch a youtube video again but
you can't be someone who never watched a
YouTube video no doubt it's a terrifying
prospect and you're not human if you
don't feel even a little bit overwhelmed
by cultural changes of this nature and
even more overwhelmed when you realize
that the changes are coming at an
accelerating rate and devices like the
Google glasses will be ubiquitous not
tomorrow or next year but in a
relatively short time you begin to
wonder who decides what comes next in
the postwar 50s and 60s manufacturers
created dozens and dozens of new
appliances for the growing number of
middle-class homes appliances that they
perhaps didn't need but a capitalist
economy is structured toward growth
toward profit corporations needed to
build and create new products for
consumption
you see the same trend today in
technology and social media the
difference is that in the past it was
physical products that you could put
somewhere the advances and upgrades in
tech instead have the effect of small
gradual unsolicited alterations to our
personalities and that's weird there's a
lot of literature out there already on
the way the Internet age is affecting
our minds and social behavior many say
that it's a boon connecting us to more
people and more information others say
that social media only gives the
illusion of being more connected when in
fact we are more separated and alone
there is truth to both I'm sure and this
is only the first chapter in a long
story but this weekend I had the
pleasure to take a trip to the beautiful
desert east of Los Angeles and sitting
there among the sparse vegetation
decompressing after 30 weeks of logs I
had the feeling that social media
doesn't so much corrupt our ability to
be social as it does our ability to be
alone to savor that much-needed
solitude and silence in which so many
things are reconciled and put in their
proper place and maybe it's this
condition of Perpetual half-measures
half alone half together all the time
that we should be most careful to guard
against if not for the culture at large
then at least for ourselves from the
first big swoop off the top of the jar
right
down to the last so far happy young
faces at all times make sure you've got
Peter Pan peanut butter on hand